[Musica]
chi ha ucciso il gatto di schroedinger è
una bella domanda anzi è una bella
storia e come tutte le storie c'è
bisogno di protagonisti di eventi ma
anche spesso e soprattutto di
un'ambientazione
esattamente come la storia che sto per
raccontarvi vienna 1913 stava per
parlare in una conferenza il grande
albert einstein era l'auditorium
dell'università di vienna e tutte le
persone hanno iniziato a partire
all'alba per riuscire a raggiungere
l'auditorium volevano occupare i posti
la sala ne conteneva 5 mila ed era già
colma alle 10 del mattino lui avrebbe
dovuto parlare a mezzogiorno la gente
continuava a scendere dalla stazione
arrivava con i bus con le macchine
arrivava a piedi per sentirlo parlare
la prima conferenza del grande albert
einstein a vienna pane neeson le 12 ea
non riescono ancora a sistemare le
persone nella sala a differenza di
quello che uno si aspetta gli austriaci
hanno
fatto riba ribaltato tutte le regole a
quei tempi non c'era la distanza di
sicurezza e quindi hanno iniziato a
calcare sì c'erano 7 mila persone in
quella sala entra albert einstein e
inizia a parlare tutti si aspettavano
che avrebbe parlato della relatività
1905 ha scritto alla sua famosa
equazione che voi conoscete non ve lo
chiedo so che la conosce è quella quello
che aveva fatto invece quel giorno lui
aveva iniziato a parlare di un'altra
cosa dell'arcobaleno rosso arancione
giallo verde blu esattamente colori con
cui vediamo l'arcobaleno sempre in
quest'ordine sempre gli stessi colori
ogni colore alla sua frequenza
inversamente proporzionale la sua
lunghezza d'onda e quindi la sua energia
come diceva planck plan che l'aveva
detto nel 1900 nessuno gli aveva creduto
einstein aveva detto prendiamo per buono
quello che ha detto blanc e facciamogli
fare un passaggio successivo tutti
allibiti in quella sala non ci volevano
credere perché lui aveva detto delle
cose che non era scritto su nessun libro
di scuola aveva iniziato a parlare di
luce che si propaga sotto forma di
quanti di energia oggi noti con il nome
di fotoni proviamo a studiarla così dice
einstein bene chi lo prende subito alla
lettera è una persona seduta lì in
ultima fila io simpatizzo sempre con le
ultime file dove mi mettevo io di solito
da ragazza ecco era seduto erwin hicheur
leading are di anni ne aveva 26 nel 1913
e non era nessuno a differenza di ain
sente di anni ne aveva 8 di più shading
non aveva fatto ancora niente a nessuno
lo conosceva e aveva preso punti
semplicemente era affatto fisica ed era
un grande appassionato del mondo
dell'infinitamente piccolo esattamente
quello di cui albert einstein e aveva
parlato e poi andato nel bar bar bar
centrale andava sempre lì è al capolinea
perdere tempo anche einstein quel giorno
arriva non c'era posto lo fa sedere al
suo tavolino lo conosce e lo riempie di
domande da quel giorno del 1913 a vienna
un sabato inizia l'amicizia più lunga
della storia e l'amicizia più bella e
importante della storia del mondo
dell'infinitamente piccolo tra albert
einstein erwin schrodinger che iniziano
a mandarsi dalle lettere e non finiranno
più fino al 1955 anno di morte di albert
einstein di cosa parlavano del mondo
dell'infinitamente piccolo entrambi
saranno tra i creatori e un nuovo modo
di vedere il mondo della fisica
quantistica la fisica quantistica ce
l'abbiamo già nelle mani tutti i giorni
quando usiamo i telefonini e lettori cd
dvd le tac
i chip al silicio sono applicazioni
della fisica quantistica schroedinger
dirà una cosa di più 1925 scrive la sua
equazione i accatagliato dei suddetti
uguale h psi non vale più quello che
dice newton baste vecchio newton basta
studiano sui libri di scuola sempre
pieno delle equazioni di newton ora c'è
la formula di schroedinger che ha preso
il suo posto dice tutt'altro la formula
di schroedinger non è più il mondo che
raccontava newton quello che viviamo noi
oggi shading era il suo successore
machine learning e tra le applicazioni
della formula di schroedinger che noi
oggi usiamo e vivremo per le
applicazioni future la seconda
rivoluzione quantistica quella che
stiamo per vivere oggi è proprio parte
da machine learning c'è un qualcosa che
prende le decisioni per noi ripulito da
tutte le insofferenze i sentimenti tutte
quelle del ds presente i talk show basta
che quelli che urlano ho sentito l'altro
giorno henry kissinger che parlava era
il consigliere di nixon ai tempi della
guerra in vietnam che parlava del
conflitto in ucraina con la russia ha
parlato pulito ha usato ma potrà
spiegare la situazione
come da noi quello macellaio quello
quelle un hitler quelle mato no i
pollici fanno così ripulito tutto da
dalla chiacchiera inutile il machine
learning aiuta anche in questo che ha
ucciso il gatto di schroedinger per il
momento vi dico che schroedinger è vivo
è vivo e vive insieme a noi scrittura
tramite un battito di ciglia possibile
nuovo la mano e comunico con qualcuno
dall'altra parte del pianeta possibile
robot che vivono con noi a provano
sentimenti possibili teletrasporto
possibile violando un fotone nessuno lo
può intercettare perché se lo intercetta
lo distrugge pensa pensa che rivoluzione
stiamo per vivere penso onde cerebrali
che fanno muovere cose pensate alla
disabilità che rivoluzione penso mi
concentro emette onde beta possa alzare
la tapparella posso guidare posso fare
qualsiasi cosa che ha ucciso il gatto di
schroedinger
1935 intanto chi lo ha creato la
creatura di schroedinger
1935 in uno scambio di lettere con
albert einstein naturalmente dice che
noi mettiamo un gatto in una scatola con
un dispositivo contenente un veleno
mortale è un nucleo atomico radioattivo
il momento in cui il nucleo atomico
radioattivo decade emette un sistema
nella scatola che uccide ai gatto e
mette un veleno nel momento in cui non
sappiamo quando però deca del nucleo
atomico radiative questo è il problema
quando verrà quando decadrà partirà il
veleno al gatto more schroedinger ha
pensato questo perché voleva tirare
fuori una cosa reale per far crollare la
teoria di niels bohr la teoria ortodossa
della fisica quantistica che era il
grande nemico di albert i due hanno
fatto comunella per far crollare questa
teoria che stava prendendo piene del
mainstream della fisica quantistica
borea e la probabilità che esista la
realtà non esiste la realtà in assenza
di misure diceva bor cielo ed ingresso
in mente a questo paradosso la cosa
inter non è il paradosso è che lui dice
allora finché non guardiamo nella
scatola il gatto è vivo e morto allo
stesso tempo non possiamo dire niente se
non che vivo e morto allo stesso tempo
il paradosso sta nel fatto che gli
invii avversari e schroedinger e tutti
gli altri si appropriano di questo
esperimento mentale che è valido nel
mondo dell'infinitamente piccolo quindi
non esiste nessun gatto che viene messo
nella scatola e allora dice no siamo noi
che quando guardiamo nella scatola
determiniamo il risultato
dell'esperimento e quindi lo stato di
salute del gatto se ne appropria board e
tutti useranno quel modo di parlare quel
modo di dire ma tutti tazze quadri
canzoni cartoni animati e tutti citano
il gatto di schroedinger io sono
ossessionate da questo gatto ne parlano
tutti barack obama 20 gennaio 2009 casa
bianca stati uniti d america primo
discorso da presidente si vince si perde
allo stesso tempo in politica funziona
come per il famoso gatto steve jobs 30
settembre 2011
palo alto california ultima convention
prima di morire gli oggetti che abbiamo
in mano se non li tocchiamo esistono e
non esistono allo stesso tempo come per
il famoso gatto marks spencer
editorialista del new york times in un
articolo a tutta pagina parla del
politico micron e come il primo politico
gatto di schroedinger della storia
mary susino la portinaia dello stabile
dove vivo a una maglietta con una
scritta qui davanti a me be that che se
li faccia una signora susi noman sa cosa
vuol dire il nome di una band ma sa cosa
vuol dire che andava trovo sia con
questa maglietta mi fa ma certo il gatto
e forse è morto
no signora susi loro gatto non è forse
morto e gatto e sia vivo sia porto allo
stesso tempo ma io non so che voi lo
citati a sproposito il gatto arish
radica ne parlate continuamente lo vedo
ovunque se io uso il mio stato per
emettere un messaggio nessuno lo può
intercettare perché se lo intercetta
loro distrugge lo stato compare solo
dopo aver fatto una misura è per questo
che le grandi aziende lo usano usano
questo sistema per trasmettere messaggi
sicuri la intel volkswagen la bosch in
germania creato un progetto pilota che
usa sensori quantistici che dicono come
funziona l'attività cerebrale quando
proviamo
un'emozione un sentimento o anche quando
proviamo dolore
noi possiamo capire un attimo prima cosa
proviamo quando proviamo un dolore
fortissimo atroce potremmo sapere cosa
proviamo il giorno della nostra morte
che ha ucciso il gatto di schroedinger
per il momento vi dico che sceglie
dinger è morto 4 gennaio
1961 è morto e sulla sua tomba sono
andate a vederla in tirolo cioè le sue
creazioni la sua equazione a fianco una
frase che ha scritto ha detto
perché ciò che esiste non è che esiste
perché lo conosciamo perché lo vediamo
gli parliamo lo sentiamo e ciò che non
esiste non è che non esiste perché non
lo vediamo mai non lo sentiamo mai
esistiamo perché siamo perpetui e se uno
muore ma non è detto che non esista e se
esistiamo non è detto che siamo morti
ogni essere è un solo essere reading
aveva capito tutto ecco perché einstein
gli piaceva questa amicizia ecco perché
gli piaceva per vincere dinger niente
reale che ha ucciso il gatto di
schroedinger niente reale lo diceva già
john lennon che ha ucciso il gatto di
schroedinger il gatto è vivo è vivo e
fuori dalla scatola siamo noi che siamo
dentro la scatola impariamo a fare come
faceva il gatto impariamo a vivere dai
gatti impariamo a celebrare ogni giorno
come se fosse l'unico impariamo da
quello che fanno loro viviamo il qui
adesso è comodo pensare che la realtà
esiste a prescindere come diceva aiuto
nel vecchio e polveroso newton o non è
così
ora c'è tutto il mondo del possibile
della della probabilità ci sono
tantissime strade che si aprono davanti
a noi se uno muore non è detto che sia
morto lo diceva r miss ridinger si muore
tre volte nella vita la prima volta si
muore quando il nostro cuore smette di
battere la seconda volta se muore perché
il nostro nome viene pronunciato per
l'ultima volta la terza volta si muore
perché iniziamo a smettere di pensare
positivamente al domani la cosa positiva
è che noi oggi possiamo agire su tutte
queste tre morti perché siamo eterni e
immortali ogni essere un solo essere né
possono essere io a decidere la forma da
dare al mio universo
mi viene in mente
mi viene in mente bukowski
se vuoi trovarci farlo fino in fondo
altrimenti non iniziare neanche se vuoi
provarci fallo fino in fondo questo
potrebbe voler dire perdere mogli mariti
parenti e forse la tua mente se vuoi
provarci fallo fino in fondo questo
potrebbe voler dire gelare su una
panchina al parco potrebbe voler dire
derisione schermo isolamento
l'isolamento è il regalo tutto il resto
è solo per te la prova della tua
resistenza di quanto realmente desideri
farlo e lo farai malgrado rifiuto e le
peggiori avversità
se vuoi provarci farlo fino in fondo non
esiste un'altra sensazione come questa
sarai solo con gli dei e le notti
arderanno tra le fiamme fallo fino in
fondo
guiderà e la vita verso la risata
perfetta e sarà l'unico buon
combattimento
che c'è sono gabriella greison è questo
il mio hotel per voi ciao
[Applauso]